several positive things have happened
that would justify us to the increase in
ela that we approved today incidentally
I didn't say by how much we
substantially accommodated the request
put forward by the bank of greece
recalibrated over one week so the
increase would be 900 million over one
week two years second point let me say
that the liquidity provision according
to our rules was never meant to be
unlimited and unconditional here it's
just one good opportunity to clarify
some confusion oh by the way let me
preface this saying that we take these
these sort of criticisms very very
seriously and I want I don't want to
underplay the difficulty that the ECB
and the county councillor DCB had in
last few weeks about having to take
decisions between making sure the
payments start the payment system
continue to work the liquidity provision
the monetary policy not to amass
successive race for the Euro system at
the same time all at the same time but
just let me make one legal point first
of all the payment system that P some
people have referred to doesn't have to
do with liquidity provisions there is an
article in the treaty that says that
basically the ECB has responsibility to
promote the smooth functioning of the
payment system but this has to do with
the functioning of target to the
distribution of notes coins so not not
with the provision of liquidity which
actually is ruled is regulated by a
different provision in the article 18.1
in ECB statute first of all in order to
achieve the objectives of the ESC be the
ECB and the national central banks may
conduct credit operations with credit
institutions and other market
participants with lending based on an
adequate collateral this is the treaty
provision
but our operations were not monetary
policy operations but ela operations and
so they are subsequently regulated by a
separate agreement which makes explicit
reference to the necessity to have
sufficient collateral so all in all
liquidly provisions never been
unconditional and unlimited